nostradamus
strikes again
yesterday the fbi raided donald trump's
home
at mar-a-lago and in this case i truly
hate to say
i told you so
this timing was even weirder than
you know about this because i've i've
suggested things like this might happen
before but the timing was really really
weird because i told you so or more
specifically i told my friend ali stucky
so about one hour before the raid took
place
allie and i were here and ali was in
nashville we were filming some stuff we
were discussing whether or not we would
bet on trump winning re-election in 2024
and i said look i love the guy i voted
for him twice if he were the nominee in
2024 i would happily vote for him a
third time
i even think most people would vote for
him especially after this terrible
administration we've got right now but
i said i would not bet
on trump winning in 2024 because there's
just one reason
i am not sure that the powers that be
will let him win talking about the fbi
the doj the deep state the crooks who
changed all the election rules last time
the big tech cartel the whole blob i'm
not just talking about biden or the
house democrats i'm talking about the
whole
array of established interests i just
don't know that they will let trump win
whatever the voters want okay when we're
talking about the liberal establishment
we're talking about groups that have a
lot of power
the groups that already use that power
to rig the election in 2020 i don't see
any reason that they wouldn't do it
again
now that they are even more fully
ensconced in power
is just something about trump more so
than other republicans they just hate
this guy they hate the way that he
shakes things up and i just didn't know
if they're gonna let him do it within an
hour of that conversation with ali
the fbi raided president trump's home
mar-a-lago reportedly looking for
classified documents that he had there
that was the that was the presumptive
basis for the raid
the fbi which never raided hillary
clinton for the 30 000 emails containing
classified info that she had on a server
at her home the fbi which has yet to
raid hunter biden's home despite video
evidence of him committing national
security compromising crimes that same
fbi is now focusing all of its attention
on raiding the home of joe biden's most
prominent and most popular political
opponent
not just a former president don't forget
the guy who is currently leading
in the polls by a long shot for the
republican nomination in 2024 the
biggest political threat to joe biden
now ironically the raid has a
paradoxical effect on the one hand it
proves my point
it shows that the establishment will do
absolutely anything to stop trump in
2024. on the other hand
it makes trump's admirers myself
included
even more inclined than perhaps we
already were to support him again
where does that leave us does that leave
us with
trump 2024
desantis 2024 cruz 2024
biden 2024
no
it leaves us with a banana republic in
2022 and no end in sight to the
corruption right now go to alto ira.com
michael cryptocurrency may represent the
money of the future especially now that
the u.s dollar is basically not worth
the paper that it's printed on
crypto is one of the most exciting
investment opportunities to come around
for a long time
but what about taxes did you know that
you can trade bitcoin ethereum and over
80 other cryptocurrencies in a tax
advantaged ira with alto crypto ira you
can avoid or defer the taxes
when trading crypto like bitcoin alto
offers alternative investment
opportunities like private companies
crypto funds real estate venture capital
and more no commissions no paperwork you
create an account in as little as 10
minutes you can invest with as little as
10 dollars through alto's integration
with coinbase you get secure trading 24
7 150 plus available coins on their
interface including bitcoin ethereum and
cardano alto offers industry-leading
security the advanced encryption
standard for wallets and private keys
and alternative investment opportunities
through some of the world's most
recognized platforms and fund partners
plus there are multiple ways to fund
your account you can make a cash
contribution transfer from an existing
ira roll over an old 401k open an alto
crypto ira with as little as 10 bucks go
to autoira.com michael that's a l t o i
r a dot com slash michael start
investing in cryptocurrency today
altoira.com
michael
absolutely
crazy news story
even though i predicted it
even though i said this sort of thing is
going to happen because trump is just
different and they hate trump in a
special way and you're going to see all
sorts of political stops you know
absolutely no holes barred you're going
to see
illegal actions you already have seen
illegal actions by these same groups by
the fbi by the doj
even though i predicted it it doesn't
make it less
offensive and less shocking
that we're now
descended into such banana republic
level nonsense that you've got the
president sicking the federal government
seeking federal law enforcement on his
main political opponent
if this happened in
in brazil
forget if this happened in syria this
happened in iraq
we would we would say this is
illegitimate this is ridiculous
what a sham democracy they've got in
these sorts of places
and now we're seeing it happen in our
own country
pathetic what was this about
according to the new york times
according to the the paper of record of
the liberal establishment the raid was
focused on material that trump had
brought with him to mar-a-lago his
private club in residence after he left
the white house
those boxes contained many pages of
classified documents
oh he had classified documents in places
he shouldn't have had them like hillary
like hillary clinton on her server 30
000 emails with classified material and
she just wiped it clean before before
federal law enforcement could find it
not that not that federal law
enforcement was ever really going to
look
like kind of like that
by the way the president has the right
to declassify whatever he wants
so
i'm not saying it's it's right for trump
to take classified material if that's
even what he did
but
while he was president he could have
declassified that material you're
telling me the fbi is going to raid the
home of a former president and
even even more shocking future
presidential candidate likely future
presidential candidate over the
presidential records act
that's it
i don't think so
new york times goes on trump also faces
a criminal investigation from the
justice department over alleged efforts
to overturn the 2020 election results
there we go okay now we're getting a
little more real
they're upset because donald trump
pointed out that the election was rigged
he just pointed it out they changed all
the election rules right before the
election and they made it much more
vulnerable to fraud even by the standard
of barack obama and in some cases they
violated the state constitutions
in different states
yeah it was rigged duh
duh hello any everyone knows that the
libs even admitted that they rigged the
thing there was a whole big magazine
article afterward how we rigged the
election such that it was more
advantageous for democrats and and
disadvantageous to republicans
and then when you say
write back to them what they just told
you they say you're not allowed to say
that that's a crazy conspiracy theory
believe us don't believe your own lying
eyes
finally new york times says prosecutors
have also reportedly asked about
trump's alleged attempt to pressure vice
president mike pence to overturn the
results of the election so now
trump isn't even allowed to publicly say
that he wants the vice president to
invoke a kind of measure that we saw
not that is frequently invoked in
american history but which is not
unprecedented to object to the
certification of certain slates of
electors in the election we did see this
in the 1870s and and there was a process
that came out of that which is a process
that senator cruz and representative
paul gosar suggested that we have a kind
of presidential election commission
afterward to analyze the many
irregularities that took place in 2020
when they changed all the rules in some
cases illegally
so all that what that now that's the
so what's the basis for the rate it's
that
or it's the the fact that he may have
had some documents at his home like
hillary clinton did or the fact that he
complained about the election what is it
what is it
as far as i can tell there are three
options here for what this raid is about
there are there are only three uh the
the
most shallow option is that this was
just routine fbi work this is just
routine doj nothing to do with biden
nothing to do with stopping trump from
running in 2024 or none of that right
i think we can dismiss that out of hand
you don't raid the president's home over
the stupid presidential records act
second option here the this is an
attempt to kill trump's candidacy in
2024 in the cradle this is an attempt to
wield federal law enforcement to stop
trump from running in 2024 because the
democrats think that he would beat them
and they just simply will not allow him
to be president again
and they can't beat him at the ballot
box in a fair and square election so
they're gonna just raid his home and try
to stop him from running in 2024.
or there's a third possibility this is
the 4d chess possibility
that actually this was an attempt to
ensure
a trump
candidacy in 2024
that by raiding the home by targeting
trump he becomes a martyr whatever
support other candidates we're getting
in the republican party now that goes
right back to trump
these republicans say we got to double
down if they're going to come after him
he's got to be our nominee and that in a
kind of 4d chess way that's what the
democrats want because they feel that
they can beat him in 2024. those are the
three options
which do i think is most likely number
two
i think this
i don't think that the democrats play 4d
chess all that well sometimes they do
sometimes sometimes people in politics
play 4d chess but
when you're looking at a situation
especially where there's so many
variables where things can spiral out of
control usually the simpler answer is
correct
in this case the idea that it was just
routine fbi work i think is absurd and
not backed up by president the idea that
it was 4d chess and they really secretly
want to support trump or what i don't
really buy that i think the establish i
think i think that my thesis from the
very beginning was correct and i think
it's being proven more correct every day
the libs simply will not tolerate
a donald trump
second term
and they will do everything they can
even if it
throws the the nation into a kind of
banana republic status even if it
violates the law even if it violates all
of our political norms they will do
anything it takes they will use any
means necessary to stop trump 2024.
i'm so glad you like that clip now hold
up stop you got to ring that bell we've
hit 1 million subscribers that's great
thrilled about that we need to hit 1
billion okay we have to we have to we
have no other choice so ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you